pride a Pritts burg PA big-time movie
star and what do people say on the
street city like they usually pronounce
my name wrong what it you got it right
okay so that was actually great okay so
what are they saying what did they say I
mean usually they want to talk about
well though see the like my kid loves
pee-wee Herman we watch your movie five
times a day with peewee or it's you know
when I'm going through airport TSA it's
like oh it's the werewolf oh my god I
get a lot of that and if it's women then
it's usually something about Magic Mike
which one do you like hearing I don't
mind a mom I mean it's all what's wrong
do not like hearing like I don't like
like touching me while I'm eating oh
yeah I mean like so it's probably it's a
conditional like it's all good sometimes
like they want to you know like selfie
like they'll sit down at the booth with
a camera like a mouthful I can't even
talk cuz my mouth is so full and you
know so you get it sometimes you get
strange situations thrown at you even if
your wife is there less so with my wife
around you know she's Colombian there's
there's a chance that you might
disappear okay does your wife get that
kind of treatment from guys the official
introduction the movie is bottom of the
ninth which hits theaters tomorrow
available as a video on demand
Burt Young is in this movie Young is in
the studio right now oh do you think
there we go okay do you think fritzy
looks like Vince Young our offense young
burn young so it's so the former actor
from rocky uncle Paulie now be honest
Joe does does he look like well I feel
like we should do a scene from the movie
or like you know a this ain't no pie
eating contest
holy give Joe your rocky impersonation
burgess Meredith there oh I was
wondering if he wasn't doing anything
next 30 years you might wouldn't mind
marrying me very much and that's
Stallone d why don't you do Burt young
that's who you look like there are four
burgers when I got off the plane at
rocky 4 he goes I don't like these guys
maybe they don't like using on too much
neither what so Joe just got done with a
movie just wrapped with the doppelganger
yeah I didn't know that all right so
this is a movie you kind of have a
second chance in life you go to prison
you come back yeah and you're gonna you
have a baseball phenom that you're going
to be managing your wife is in this
movie as well yeah okay so back and then
go Joe yeah I play an it's called bottom
of the ninth I play a like a 19 year old
19 year old kid who was a baseball
phenom he grew up in the Bronx in the
shadow Yankee Stadium and winds up
getting drafted by the Yankees so the
pride of all the Bronx one night he's
out with his neighborhood friends and
gets into a fight hits a kid the kid
falls backward smacks his head on the
curb and and I get nine years in prison
for it I get another nine years tacked
on for violence in prison for basically
like staying alive doing what she had to
do to stay alive in prison I get out 18
years later in my late 30s and return to
the Bronx to try to put my life back
together after missing my mother's
funeral
I missed baseball I missed the Yankees
and I also wind up running into the girl
whose heart I broke at 19 when I went in
and through the film it's a story of
redemption and and what like what
someone who made a mistake as a kid has
to go through in order to feel like they
deserve good things in their life again
and I wind up getting a second shot at
baseball through an old coach played by
Michael Rispoli
from the deuce great actor and he calls
me up and says
how'd you like to have a job back in
baseball and through coaching I wind up
at bat versus this like rehabbing former
Sai Young winner with a screw loose
played by Brian Wilson like the beard
sans beer so people like watch the movie
they don't even know it's him oh my god
that was a relief pitcher yeah that
former world champion Brian Wilson crazy
but amazing like I love this guy
and and and so I threw this kind of like
pitching battle against him in a
practice everybody sees that I still I
still have it I still got the stuff and
so I wanted getting a second chance at
baseball through the minor leagues as
I'm trying to like put my life back
together and then of course bump into
this woman that I was in love with when
I was 19 when I went in and that gets
rekindled too but how do you act how do
you not bring in real life to acting
when you're with your wife like how does
that work is it harder to work with your
wife because no I think are you acting
yes very much
because I'm playing a different
character you know I'm playing a guy who
got out of prison after 18 years and and
and doesn't really trust himself you
know if you're like beating a guy that
there's bare hands or you know so you
know he gets out and what's the love
scenes aren't awkward well you know well
here's the thing so it's supposed to be
awkward because this is a guy who is
like hasn't been around a woman in 18
years let alone her and feels guilty for
hurting her and throwing her life off
course and so you know when I kiss her
in the movie I'm kissing her in
character which is weird to them
demonstrator demonstrate that on Pauly
you got to do what you got to do to get
by so you know there's an amount of it -
yeah that is that is strange but in
those moments I'm the character kissing
my wife who's playing a character not
you know it's not me kissing her
so that's way too deep for me does that
make yeah I get it but I but there's
also a history between my wife and I
that then becomes easy I know little
tricks to make her smile and she knows a
little
to do the same to me that are indicative
of people that have spent a lot of time
together so that actually helps because
you know each other so well what's uh
what's your baseball background I know
you you played sports in high school and
you know football as well but yeah I
play football is gonna play college
basketball but I went for I went for
theater which does it go how did that
but but did you get injured and
therefore you went into theater after
you got injured didn't you injure your
knee I did yeah I injured um I tore my
MCL returning to kick off against
Ringgold high school which was joe
Montana's high school funny enough yeah
cheap shot artist there you know yeah
hammering so I tore my MCL returning to
kick off and you know it made me start
thinking about what I really wanted to
do down the line you know western
Pennsylvania Sports were really
competitive so you go home and it's
western Pennsylvania where they love
their football and you say to your
parents I want to go into acting
well I knew from the time I was a kid I
was an artist in my heart and I knew
that if I didn't want up doing something
that involve that I was never gonna be
satisfied so it was that point that made
me think what do I really want to do but
at that point still I don't know if that
was a possibility to go be an artist
professionally so my plan was to go to
college to play basketball and and I was
gonna go into federal law enforcement I
had a cousin in the FBI and I was
talking to him about how to get in there
and what branch I wanted to go into and
my high school had a TV studio and they
had cameras and I would take them out on
the weekends and write movies for my
friends like I wrote a full-length
feature in high school and I'll write TV
shows and I would cast my friends and so
I kind of backed toward into acting or
theatre through like filmmaking as a kid
and and then I wound up trying out for
Carnegie Mellon drama school and I got
in which was like super hard to get into
so I got in with a scholarship and that
was it and so that was like how am i
that was how i launched in it so it
wasn't necessarily I got hurt and then
wound up over here it was like no I was
just trying to I just knew that was who
I want you did other things you you were
a roadie for a band he
yeah in between gigs as an actor yeah my
friend John Feldman's the lead singer of
this band Goldfinger and he was like hey
man do you have anything going on next
month and I was not you know just
hanging out struggling artist lifestyle
and he's like do you want to come out on
tour with us we're gonna do Australia
New Zealand Hawaii Canada us I said sure
yeah
so I would just throw drunk kids off the
stage every night could you do a movie
off that may be probably an absurd house
- all right well now you're talking yeah
I think Roadhouse is AG right there's
some great lines in Roadhouse I love
Roadhouse man ain't don't hurt course
yeah yeah let's do I don't we do another
Roadhouse wait are we doing it you could
play Sam Elliott we get your mustache
you start growing it out yeah yeah I got
smoked some heaters or you could be the
the guy who owns the tower the evil guy
Oh loans in town you know I'm saying do
I get a love interest you could have a
ton if you're running the town man yeah
I want Michelle Pfeiffer let's call it
okay all right it's good get Pauly see
if you can get David E Kelly on and ask
him if Michelle can come out and play
we're on it okay
how important are the Steelers to you
still what do you mean still well I
don't know board me torture me shoots
under the fingernail ward or a Super
Bowl for the Steelers well okay so but I
was there in Super Bowl 43 I witnessed
them win so I'm gonna take the Oscar
like no offense guys but I got to take
the Oscar way now it's the Best
Supporting Actor not actor academy more
I'll take it all right here's the thing
like I think that they're gonna win
again before Ben's done there I said it
oh I like him I like there's less drama
this year you very much have you met Ben
oh yeah we just had dinner when I was
back in Pittsburgh a few months ago yeah
no I know Ben I hung out with him a
bunch of times I know like most of the
guys I was at Ryan shazier wedding
recently yeah so we're buddies that had
to be pretty emotional
incredible right
yeah um he was told 18 months ago that
he was never gonna walk again yeah never
going to walk you're not going to walk
you're not gonna get to play with your
kid and there he is walking down the
aisle like bouncing down the aisle
bouncing out the steps dancing all night
like he's incredible he's just such a
strong and I don't know if he'll ever be
able to play again but you know I I just
I just hope he's able to live a life
then that's all I like I know that he
wants to have goals but I look at it and
I go I just I just hope he's healthy
just to be able to you know play with
your kids and do normal things but
that's a sign of a champion I know in in
in the mind when your goal is the play
again if your goal is to play again like
look where it's gotten him so far yeah
you know he's now defying the odds the
guy's a miracle the movie is bottom of
the ninth it hits theaters tomorrow
Bert Young is one of the stars and Joe
of course is leading the charge here I
was also noticing a couple things yes um
Metallica are you big Metallica fan yeah
huge okay did you play Metallica at your
wedding yes I did I hired violin players
and cello players for the wedding you
know to play the songs when you're
walking down the aisle and wait wait
take me back to the conversation when
you sit down with your wife and you say
Sophia I'm thinking I got this great
idea well Metallica well my wife is
pretty cool
for starters but but the other side of
it like I had heard a violin cello
string version of nothing else matters
and it's beautiful like it is gorgeous
like google it at home you know it's
beautiful so I hired these violin
players and cellist and I said could you
could you convert this to violin cello
and play that when I walked down the
aisle and they said sure of course and
and so we're walking down the aisle and
my mom turns to me and she's like my
gosh this song is beautiful you know and
I said it's Metallica mom and my buddy
Patrick from college is like giving me
the medal
as I'm walking down the aisle you know
this is great my lawyer was like nodding
his head like but it sounds like this
beautiful piece of classical music when
you convert it and I think there was
like a Swedish House Mafia song that we
played when we were walking down off the
altar you know so yeah that's fun can
you afford to let yourself go like your
body what does that mean I mean war I'm
an actor so every role isn't like you
know it isn't a giant supernatural
powered werewolf no but I'm not for a
movie role but let's say you just said
you know I'm not working out or gonna
I'm gonna let myself go a little bit
here well like I mean I just ate my way
through Italy like you and me we'll take
our shirts off let's just let me see if
you let yourself go I mean well so
there's a thing as like with me my body
wants to be skinny I was a super skinny
kid growing up like I was a kid in ninth
grade like led the league in points
rebounds I thought my end-of-the-year
review is gonna be spotless what could
they say and they said you need to gain
upper body strength you're too skinny
that was their comment and at that time
in ninth grade I couldn't do one pull-up
couldn't do one dip and we had to do
tests like in football everybody to line
up on either side of a dip bar and it's
like go as many as you can
I couldn't get one like it wasn't even
like I was in the middle and I was a
captain of the team I didn't get like a
ton or even like mid-range zero weakest
dude on the team it pissed me off so
badly that embarrassment and the shame
that I spent the next I don't know 20
years making sure that I would never
have that kind of embarrassment again
you know which is why I like so I wrote
a book about bodybuilding
you know simon & schuster approached me
they're like we want you to write a
follow-up to like Arnold's encyclopedia
of bodybuilding and I was actually
shooting a movie with Arnold at the time
and Arnold's like whatever you need let
me know I'll help you never wear
whatever way you want you take Arnold do
I think I could take Arnold yeah like
now yeah
why would I want to do that no no just I
did you know we'd like to ask these
questions he's my buddy man like I mean
you mean like could you if you're
talking like Conan the Barbarian Arnold
Arnold now
well current I'm gonna guess you can
write but if I said you at your best
against Conan the Barbarian lines right
now what depending on my answer I mean
it's great publicity for the movie
coming up I mean bottom of the ninth
which oh man this would be this would be
an interesting simulator like me at the
height of like True Blood ooh
shape I was also boxing at the time like
a lot okay
versus Arnold Conan the Barbarian this
would be interesting you know you're in
the Octagon I got the reach only one guy
gets out I get out Conan or werewolf
yeah yeah is there a madden we can tell
you madden simulator what about Conan
O'Brien instead of Conan the Barbarian
could you take Conan he's wired he's a
wiry guy smart yeah he could outsmart
you know the sweet sign yes but I and I
you know I'm never on these lists but I
always wonder when they say the hottest
bachelor alive like how many mirrors do
you guys have in your house we go back
to that so as soon as that happened the
Bachelor of the Year whatever was
someone said to me I think it was Mario
Lopez he was like that's not gonna last
long
I'm say watch it's not gonna last long
that's it all right whatever you know
and sure enough like vacate or not
you're not on the list anymore
no man that was it was very short-lived
once you get that title
anga last for long but if you're that
good-looking do you look in the mirror
all the time or do not look in the
mirror all the time I don't care I'm
like a typical guy if I can't get out of
house in less than 30 seconds like them
wrong
you know I should be ashamed of my shoes
they're typical guys over there Joe
you're not a typical guy talking about
I'm just trying to get out of the house
man I'm just like I'm not thinking about
all that's unless like I've been go on a
talk show which is somebody else's job
like okay you can all right the movie is
bottom of the ninth and it hits theaters
tomorrow it's great to see you thank you
for coming in good luck with your
stealers thank you for this year I
should be there's a different vibe at
Ryan's wedding it was a different vibe
it was like shaking a tree and the dead
leaves coming off how many Steelers were
there
everybody everybody yeah everybody old
new yeah how bad a dancer was Ben
Roethlisberger I don't think Ben dance
[Laughter]
no no no didn't leave you on bail Shaw
no no man no longer Steelers for the
team for the team I'm like the guys who
want to be there and win a championship
for Pittsburgh no like those guys want
to play for winners
haider Lee there during the commercial
break Joe and I will take off our shirts
so you'll be able to feel we're to have
like the Jesse the body versus Macho Man
pose down brother if Tatum came in would
it be on like would you guys the
Channing Tatum like what would happen if
he came in
oh we just like laugh we'd see each
other from across the room would just
laugh hysterically the kind of laughter
that can only come from the two men and
spend months of time do you understand
the bonding that happens when you do
that when's the last time you had a song
[Laughter]
and that'll be the last time that song
has ever uh never on no man that was it
that was a game that was a big boy I
feel awkward cuz I had a song on last
night I was gonna okay you just took the
quick yeah right got it flaunt it babe
hey man I mean it's actually very
freeing you have a layer brother good
luck with the movie Joe for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 2:30
Direct TV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]